Trascrizione: Jing Wen Wong
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Io, in realtà, sarei qui
per parlarvi di prevenzione:
qualcosa che conosciamo
tutti benissimo, immagino.
Prevenire...?
È meglio che curare, lo sappiamo tutti:
ed è verissimo,
non solo per quanto riguarda
l'igiene orale, da cui derivava,
ma più in generale
per quanto riguarda la salute:
sono ormai quasi due anni
che non parliamo d'altro.
Ma "prevenire" cosa significa?
Arrivare prima, no?
Prima che si verifichino problemi,
prima che sia troppo tardi,
prima che accada il peggio.
Quindi, guardiamo in avanti
e agiamo nel presente,
per evitare che poi
si possano avere problemi:
quindi un comportamento a rischio,
il contagio da parte di un germe patogeno,
ma anche un'alimentazione
o un igiene poco accurata
sono tutti ambiti possibili
di prevenzione.
Guardiamo in avanti,
e interveniamo nel presente
per evitare i problemi.
Questo è prevenire,
ed è meglio che curare,
cioè intervenire solo quando, invece,
i problemi si sono già presentati.
Ma è sempre così?
Voglio dire, è così anche quando
non si parla di salute?
Prendiamo il mio lavoro.
Io mi occupo di formazione,
e questo significa che io
accompagno le persone a imparare.
Ora, noi siamo abituati a pensare
che imparare sia un modo
per prepararci alle interrogazioni,
alle verifiche, agli esami.
Degli studenti, noi diciamo che
"sono preparati dalla scuola
fino all'Università".
E anche dopo ci iscriviamo ai master,
oppure frequentiamo corsi di formazione
per prepararci a fare bene,
fare meglio, un lavoro.
E allora ci potrebbe sembrare
che imparare e prevenire
abbiano dei punti di contatto, no?
In tutti e due casi ci prepariamo:
ma in un caso lo facciamo
con l'apprendimento,
e nell'altro con i vaccini,
o l'allenamento, o l'alimentazione.
Tutti convinti?
Vediamo un po'.
A me è sempre sembrato affascinante
che il processo di apprendimento
avesse qualcosa in comune
con quello di immunizzazione.
Pensateci bene: quando ci vacciniamo,
ci viene inoculato -
ormai lo sappiamo tutti -
una piccola quantità
di germe patogeno attenuato.
E questo serve ad allenare
il nostro organismo a reagire, no?
E quindi a scatenare
la risposta immunitaria
è come se dovessimo
ammalarci un pochettino.
Ecco: chi si occupa
di discipline cognitive
ha studiato il processo dell'apprendimento
mettendo a punto un modello
che si chiama "U-shaped learning",
l'apprendimento a forma di U.
Ha cioè osservato il fatto
che quando impariamo cominciamo
da una buona competenza
che poi all'improvviso sembra sparire,
per qualche momento, e poi ricompare.
È strano.
Questo è vero, soprattutto
per certe forme di apprendimento,
per esempio quello linguistico;
e i ricercatori che se ne occupano
hanno capito che si verifica, soprattutto,
quando abbiamo a che fare
con set di regole che sono articolati,
e dobbiamo metterli alla prova
con dei contesti complessi.
E questa, però, è la ricerca.
Veniamo un po' alla nostra esperienza:
Che cosa è successo,
quando abbiamo incominciato a imparare,
quando siamo andati a scuola?
Abbiamo incontrato qualcuno, no?
Un maestro, un insegnante,
quello che ci assegnava i compiti,
ci interrogava, ci spiegava la lezione;
ma prima di tutto,
questa persona si è rivolta a noi,
ha cominciato a chiamarci per nome,
ha cominciato a occuparsi di noi.
E questo, se voi ci pensate bene,
vuol dire un po' instaurare una relazione,
esattamente come succede
tra medico e paziente:
la relazione terapeutica.
È la base, è la premessa
di tutto quello che accadde in seguito.
Della diagnosi - dell'anamnesi,
prima ancora della diagnosi -
e poi anche della cura.
Qui, quando parliamo di cura,
parliamo di terapia.
Cos'è la terapia?
È un insieme di procedimenti,
di interventi che sono necessari
per riguadagnare un equilibrio
che si è rotto nel nostro organismo,
generando conseguenze indesiderate.
E quindi farmacologicamente,
oppure con degli interventi chirurgici;
o ricorrendo, magari,
al supporto di dispositivi esterni,
cerchiamo di ricostruire
questo equilibrio,
o meglio ancora di costruirne uno nuovo,
accettabile per il nostro organismo.
Tra l'altro, non sempre ci si riesce:
ecco perché, quando parliamo di salute,
prevenire è nettamente meglio che curare.
Anzi, la prevenzione
viene prima della cura,
mira proprio a fare in modo
che la cura non sia necessaria.
E quando parliamo di formazione?
Facciamo un parallelismo azzardato:
anche quando parliamo di formazione
esistono dei "malati",
esistono del soggetti
che necessitano di cura.
Perché sono portatori di uno squilibrio:
uno squilibrio tra le competenze
che effettivamente possiedono;
e quelle che sono, invece,
attese dagli standard di verifica,
dai requisiti d'esame,
dal mercato del lavoro.
Ecco, soprattutto quando si parla
di sfera professionale,
sempre più, ultimamente,
si lamenta uno "skill mismatch".
Che cosa significa?
Uno squilibrio, un divario
tra le competenze attese -
e in questo caso si parla
soprattutto di competenze digitali -
attese da un mercato del lavoro
completamente trasformato, ormai,
dall'innovazione tecnologica,
e le competenze che invece,
effettivamente,
i lavoratori oggi in servizio possiedono.
E allora che facciamo?
Allora corriamo ai ripari,
con corsi di formazione.
In gergo si parla
di corsi di "reskilling",
quando puntiamo alla
riqualificazione dei lavoratori
per avviarli a un mestiere nuovo,
magari perché la professione
che svolgevano
è stata resa obsoleta
dalla trasformazione digitale;
oppure si parla di corsi di "upskilling",
che significa che si forniscono
strumenti o metodi nuovi
per svolgere la stessa professione.
Quello che abbiamo capito, in formazione,
è che su questa situazione
bisogna intervenire
un po' prima che si verifichi:
bisognerebbe intervenire sin dagli anni
dell'istruzione obbligatoria.
In effetti ci sono Paesi
nei quali, sin da quest'epoca,
gli studenti vengono avviati
su percorsi molto precisi,
abbastanza rigidi quasi,
per fare in modo che le competenze
che effettivamente possederanno
alla fine del percorso
siano le competenze davvero richieste
dalle professioni
che si preparano a svolgere.
Agire prima, no?
Quindi, fare prevenzione.
Torniamo alla nostra domanda:
quindi, anche in formazione
prevenire è meglio che curare?
Dipende:
se per "cura" noi intendiamo
questa terapia della inadeguatezza,
tra l'altro tardiva,
certamente è meglio prevenire.
Però, vedete, esiste
un altro significato di cura.
Un grande filosofo del Novecento
ha definito la cura "l'atteggiamento
fondamentale dell'esserci",
cioè dell'essere umano
nel suo abitare il mondo.
Ecco, questa cura
non la definiamo filosoficamente:
questo è il mio campo.
Ma proviamo a tornare
all'esperienza, a quei due lì di prima:
il maestro e l'allievo.
Il maestro e l'allievo cosa fanno?
Si guardano negli occhi,
sono l'uno di fronte all'altro,
hanno negli occhi l'uno
la presenza dell'altro,
la sua intera realtà,
con tutte le sue perfezioni
e imperfezioni.
Che in questo caso, però,
non sono sinonimo di inadeguatezza,
ma di identità.
Ecco: chi fa formazione, prima di tutto,
ha in mente le persone come sono,
prima ancora di come potrebbero
o come dovrebbero essere.
Ecco, io credo che sia importante
ripartire da qui.
Noi abbiamo prima parlato
di prepararsi, no?
Ed è giusto, prepararsi: nella formazione
è giusto pensare alla preparazione.
Prepararsi significa guardare al futuro,
quindi alle potenzialità,
alle aspirazioni, alle aspettative.
Vuol dire anche guardare le mancanze,
le lacune, i divari;
però, gli stessi occhi
che guardano il futuro
devono essere saldamente
radicati nel presente.
Non è solo questione di tempo,
ma anche di spazio:
le persone sono qui e ora,
e per accompagnarle a imparare
bisogna essere lì con loro e per loro.
Se questo non succede,
quando questo non succede,
si verifica un po' quello
che avrete sperimentato -
chi di voi ha figli, diciamo,
tra i cinque e i dieci anni?
Prima dei cinque anni, magari,
li prendo in braccio e risolviamo;
dopo non li prendiamo più,
quindi è inutile pensarci.
Ma tra i cinque e i dieci anni,
magari c'è capitato una volta
di dover andare da qualche parte,
di avere un appuntamento,
di dover prendere un autobus,
non so, andare dal medico;
e però c'era nostro figlio
intento a giocare,
intento a guardare un cartone animato,
o a magari ammirare una vetrina.
E allora, in quel caso, cosa facciamo?
Dobbiamo andare, e allora?
Prendiamo per la mano il bambino,
lo strattoniamo e cominciamo a camminare.
Pensate al nostro atteggiamento
in quel momento:
noi siamo tutti rivolti in avanti,
al nostro obiettivo.
Non ci guardiamo indietro,
non ci voltiamo a guardare
cosa contiene la nostra mano,
quello che la nostra mano strattona.
Ecco: questo, più che un accompagnamento,
è un trascinamento.
Ed è questo quello che mi viene in mente
quando penso a un certo modo
di fare formazione,
che è un modo molto
orientato all'obiettivo,
molto consapevole del rischio da evitare,
del problema da risolvere,
e che quindi tende a mettere al sicuro
competenze e conoscenze
prima, o invece, di mettere
al centro le persone,
che sono le portatrici
di queste competenze e conoscenze.
Questo io lo definirei un modo
"preventivo" di fare formazione.
Invece vorrei provare
a ripartire dalla cura,
a mettere prima la cura.
Diciamo che la cura
è questo atteggiamento fondamentale,
questo modo di consentire per noi,
il fatto di rivolgersi agli altri,
di occuparsi di loro.
La cura è una coltivazione dell'umano.
Poi è importante avere uno scopo,
un modello, un obiettivo, assolutamente:
ma quando impariamo,
lo scopo più importante
è li davanti ai nostri occhi,
perché imparando
stiamo diventando noi stessi.
Se invece mettiamo al primo posto
i rischi, i problemi, i divari, le lacune,
noi non potremmo mai fare nient'altro
che riparare, invece di costruire.
Ecco perché io credo
che per fare formazione
si debba avere cura,
e avere cura significa
accompagnare le persone,
accompagnarle in quello
che vogliono realizzare,
condividere la fiducia
nelle loro possibilità,
nelle loro capacità
di realizzare i loro progetti,
di superare i loro problemi
e le loro paure.
Ma di farlo a modo loro,
rispettando il loro modo di essere.
Ecco: io credo che senza ripartire
da questa umanità presente,
senza coltivare la nostra
umanità presente,
non potremo mai costruire
l'umanità futura.
Perché una persona che impara
non sta anzitutto gestendo un rischio,
o risolvendo un problema:
una persona che impara,
prima di ogni altra cosa, sta crescendo.
Ed è a questo che va
accompagnata, con cura.
Grazie.
(Applausi)